play  alireza even before before the blunder  no to some extent at least he was yeah  yeah this is true putting some pressure  with black slowly  some small gains  yeah i mean bishop h3 or book c1 or  something here must  there must be a way  but i'm pretty sure that here he he was  not happy with his position he felt that  it's uncomfortable to play  yeah i asked the computer yeah minus  zero thirty five minus zero fifteen oh  no it's already ready and the game is  over  he didn't wait for h5 here like he  waited for fabi to come back  incredible round guys  yeah and how did we do in the prediction  front we got a couple of decisive games  today ooh it was nice  four draws for draw strategy didn't work  out  and with united she always predicts a  rapport win but rapper always draws so  we can count that as a correct  prediction